[Musica]
sai come si dice che le persone si
completano a vicenda Penso che sia vero
sai che mio marito è una
persona fantastica ma ha quella particolare abitudine
di fare le cose all'ultimo minuto è
sempre all'ultimo minuto sia che faccia
le valigie  per le vacanze o
deve portarmi da qualche parte e lui sa che
devo essere puntuale e questo mi fa
impazzire perché ovviamente sono un
pianificatore sono l'opposto e ho
tutto molto tempo prima organizzato nel
mio  agenda online e odio odio essere in
ritardo a volte penso che il problema
sia che sono un ingegnere e gli ingegneri di
solito sono persone molto organizzate ma
ovviamente dobbiamo fare i conti con cose che
devono funzionare per molto tempo non possiamo
fare  cose all'ultimo minuto, ma come possono gli
ingegneri progettare qualcosa ed essere sicuri
che funzionerà per così tanto
tempo non è solo una questione di organizzare la
tua agenda online, parliamo ad
esempio del sistema di trasporto che
progetti un ponte oggi e questo b  la cresta
verrà costruita diciamo nei prossimi quattro
anni e deve funzionare per 100
anni sembra incredibile ma questa è la
normalità per ogni ingegnere quindi come possono
entrare gli ingegneri progettano le cose ed essere
sicuri che lavoreranno per 50 o 100
anni  abbiamo anche un'idea dei
requisiti del sistema di traffico in
futuro
se progetto una strada oggi devo
decidere oggi che questa strada sarà
larga una determinata quantità di metri e II
deciso in base ai requisiti effettivi
del sistema di trasporto  ma siamo sicuri
che funzioneranno per i
requisiti del sistema di traffico
del futuro
bene la storia dimostra che non è
sempre stato così giusto, quindi come
possono gli ingegneri progettare le cose ed essere sicuri che
il tavolo funzionerà per una
vita così lunga  abbiamo anche un'idea di come
sarà il sistema di traffico in futuro
auto elettriche forse nessuno possiede nemmeno
più un'auto forse ci sposteremo nei fast
food come treni pedonali nascosti nei
tunnel e questo potrebbe essere  non così lontano
nel futuro quindi come è possibile progettare
qualcosa oggi ed essere sicuri
che funzionino bene per il futuro La
Norvegia ha
accettato questa sfida particolare questa è la e39 è una strada europea che
corre per 1.100 chilometri lungo la
costa occidentale  della Norvegia e oggi per guidare
da Kristiansund
nel sud della Norvegia fino a Trondheim
nel centro della Norvegia dove termina la E39 ci
vogliono 21 ore il lungo viaggio è causato
da sette tratti di traghetto lungo la strada
che ancora oggi sono l'unico modo per
attraversare alcuni di questi  fiordi prendiamoci un
momento e pensiamoci ci sono
zone lungo la e39 dove ci vogliono tre
ore per raggiungere l'ospedale più vicino
tre ore bene se hai
un'emergenza fai affidamento sugli elicotteri
bene se il tempo è abbastanza buono quindi
le persone che vivono lungo la  e39 devono essere
le persone più sane in Norvegia o le
più fortunate Sto scherzando ma un terzo della
popolazione nazionale vive lì e
viene prodotto più del 50% dell'esportazione nazionale
i  n quell'area quindi questo significa che
c'è un potenziale enorme ma questo
potenziale richiede persone e persone
richiedono servizi di cui hanno bisogno per raggiungere posti di lavoro
ospedali scuole hanno bisogno di un
sistema di trasporto efficiente e affidabile senza un
sistema di trasporto siamo come
un'isola isolata e nessuno vuole  vivere in un
luogo isolato ecco perché le persone si
spostano abbandonando le zone rurali e trasferendosi
nelle città, ecco perché abbiamo bisogno di un
sistema di trasporto efficiente e affidabile
lungo la E39 in Norvegia e che dire
dei traghetti che conosci in Norvegia quando la
gente pensa ai traghetti che offrono
pensa a questo valido mangiano a bordo
cosa sono questi validi bene
stanno bene sono una specie di frittelle oh
scusa l'ho detto bene posso condividere alcune
informazioni privilegiate con te in Norvegia la
gente pensa che il meglio sia valido si
può mangiare  o quello che mangi a bordo con le
tue fate quindi ecco perché la gente
non si piegherà mai sui traghetti va bene scherzando
ma i traghetti sono una via naturale per
il camionista  per prendersi una pausa sono
un'attrazione turistica nazionale fanno
parte della cultura norvegese le fate
rimarranno ovviamente forse ci
saranno i traghetti elettrici ad esempio ma di
sicuro il traffico del futuro non può
contare sul fatto che non solo siano puntuali
il tempo necessario per viaggiare
ma anche per l'enorme impatto che le
barche hanno sull'ambiente parliamo
di ambiente più ponti più
collegamenti fissi e meno barche potrebbero essere un
modo per ridurre l'impatto sulla
fauna marina in queste aree sono
migliaia  di specie marine così
preziose dal punto di
vista ambientale esiste anche l'area dell'acquacoltura
in Norvegia e questa attività è
considerata il secondo petrolio per la Norvegia
quindi prova a immaginare che tipo di impatto
potrebbe un aumento del rumore nelle aree di campo  avere un ambiente enorme
quindi costruiamo dei ponti bene questa
non è la cosa più semplice direi che alcuni
di questi fiordi sono davvero larghi
potrebbero arrivare fino a sei chilometri  se
possono essere anche molto lunghi e profondi più
di un chilometro quindi la
tecnologia tradizionale per i ponti
non è fattibile lì quindi cosa possiamo fare
nel 2013 il governo norvegese ha
inserito gli attraversamenti lungo la e39 in
un documento che si chiama  Piano nazionale dei
trasporti e da allora
è iniziato un processo complesso per sviluppare nuove
tecnologie per poter attraversare questi
fiordi questa potrebbe essere una delle soluzioni
ponti galleggianti è una
tecnologia esistente abbiamo ponti galleggianti in
tutto il mondo e potrebbero andare bene
anche per  il nostro caso un'alternativa potrebbe
essere un altro ben noto
ponte sospeso, ma invece di fare affidamento
sulle torri tradizionali si affidano a queste
piattaforme a gambe di tensione queste
torri galleggianti che vengono utilizzate nel campo offshore
So cosa stai pensando come può
essere questa struttura  ecologico
bene per esempio se si pensa
ai percorsi migratori degli uccelli perché questo
potrebbe essere un problema per qualcuno di questi
fiordi  quindi abbiamo un'alternativa un
sommergere che galleggia sul ponte è un
ponte sommerso ma galleggiare questa
emergenza ci aiuterà a controbilanciare
i carichi verticali della struttura
sfruttando la
forza di sollevamento di Archimede che ha ogni corpo sommerso
e questa emergenza ci sta anche
aiutando  per ridurre il carico principale del mare sulla
struttura come le onde per esempio e le
malattie una differenza enorme rispetto ai
ponti d'oltremare che sono completamente
esposti alle elezioni ambientali
come i venti e le correnti delle onde e queste
strutture sono un modo per creare un
ponte nascosto se  tu scegli la soluzione
con pontili galleggianti puoi
crearli come isola galleggiante Green Island per
ridurre al minimo l'impatto sul paesaggio ma
dobbiamo dire che non esiste una soluzione che
possa adattarsi a ogni caso l'
importante è valutare il miglior inquinamento
per ogni specifico  caso ma c'è una
cosa che puoi fare per ogni
applicazione di questa struttura in cui puoi
trovare un modo per progettare la strada
per produrre meno CO2 puoi trovare un modo
per progettare strutture più
resistenti ai carichi ambientali
puoi trovare nuovi materiali materiali
più leggeri o materiali più resistenti materiali
che ti aiutano a progettare strutture
più sicure o strutture più resilienti puoi utilizzare
i carichi di  la natura intorno a te per
creare energia verde puoi fare tante
cose ma
quanto è vecchio possibile questo è l'unico
modo per progettare per il futuro si
chiama ricerca più di 50 dottorandi sono
stati affiliati al progetto e39 in
Norvegia negli ultimi  il design di un anno per il
futuro è possibile se investi nelle
persone e nella conoscenza questa conoscenza
ti aiuterà oggi a progettare il miglior design
che puoi per il tuo futuro ha anche creato
buone pratiche perché anche la
consulenza investirà nella ricerca
crea posti di lavoro per le persone assunte  nelle
aziende crea una grande
società internazionale che investendo
in giovani professionisti provenienti da
tutto il
mondo crea crescita o  n così tanti livelli che
conosci dopo la pubblicazione che abbiamo fatto
per questa libertà di collegare molti
paesi hanno ricominciato a pensare allo
scioglimento La Norvegia sta ispirando La
Norvegia sta condividendo la sua esperienza Ho
dimenticato
questa donna fantastica è una collega
ed è la project manager  del
progetto fioor Crossing il progetto e39
in Norvegia vediamo se Nora può ispirare
altre nazioni anche su altri argomenti
solo un esempio di uguaglianza di genere a questo
punto ti chiederai chi sono io sono il
più grande fan di questa fusione che sta allagando il
ponte I'  Sono un ingegnere capo e ho lavorato
per l'amministrazione pubblica stradale di Univision
e sono responsabile
degli studi su queste fantastiche strutture
mi sono trasferito in Norvegia sei anni fa e ho
visto crescere il gruppo di persone che lavoravano a
questi progetti ho incontrato persone che
arrivavano  da tutto il mondo e ho avuto
la possibilità di studiare alcuni degli
argomenti più eccitanti per un ingegnere ho anche
avuto l'opportunità di sentirmi parte di
un grande c  ommunity che dalla
Norvegia alla Corea del Sud sta lavorando per
lo stesso obiettivo
abbiamo visto alcuni dei nostri progetti
diventare realtà e abbiamo dovuto affrontare e
dovremo affrontare avversari per i nostri
progetti discutiamo ci arrabbiamo e
lottiamo lottiamo per ciò che  credo
che non sei tu il viaggio e mi sento così fortunato di aver
avuto la possibilità di farne parte, spero davvero
che un giorno vedremo una
strada costiera III 9 completata sulla
nostra strada
anche se i politici sono stati lungimiranti le
loro priorità possono  cambia sempre
in futuro tutto può cambiare la tua
vita nel modo giusto, ma una cosa è certa che una
cosa rimarrà la conoscenza che la
Norvegia ha generato perché queste
persone ovunque saranno
saranno sicuramente le persone che potrebbero pianificare
potrebbero progettare il nostro futuro, quindi vuoi
per progettare per il futuro iniziamo ad
organizzare la nostra agenda perché
devi investire nelle persone devi investire
in conoscenza e devi iniziare a
farlo oggi
tu
[Musica]